once one thing i want to know right is
why did you decide to move to brighton
because i i i want to know this as a
brighton resident well i want to know
this as someone who was born and raised
in brighton and like you know i grew up
that's cool yeah yeah so you know i you
know still technically live in brighton
yeah um
yeah i like i remember when brighton was
a town it wasn't even a city it was a
town and now seeing
like growing up and now seeing you know
big youtubers coming there and like it's
the cool city it's a cool hip city like
i want to know like you personally since
you being such a big presence there in
terms like content creators who have
moved to brighton what made you decide
to do so
i think because felix lived there for a
long time and i had heard really nice
things from him and then like alfie and
those guys were there and there was a
couple of other like big a lot of them
were those right right there and i
didn't really get it
when i got when i went there i realized
oh it's like a mini la now i kind of get
it right right right sort of like
structure but smaller yeah
um and i went there to visit him for the
first time over like a weekend in
october like years and years ago and
then i just fell in love with it
immediately because i i've been thinking
about moving already and i was like la
is a bit too far yeah crazy yeah you
have to get visas and everything and i
was like i kind of maybe london and then
london is just a [ __ ] nightmare
it's the traffic's awful there's too
many people here it's just it was a bit
too busy for someone who grew up in a
tiny town and then we went to brighton i
was like this is lovely this is like
small the beach is there if we wanted my
friends are there feeling so prideful
right now man i'm feeling so frightened
i'm like yeah it is yeah it is
the people were just so nice and like it
was like a really strong like lgbtq yeah
yeah yeah there and everybody was just
so like progressive and nice the vegan
community was huge there yeah and i was
like this is perfect why would i live
anywhere else yeah just walking around
town was a very walkable city and it was
just really fun to do you don't get like
bombarded do you feel like walking
around town no really oh wow okay
everyone's pretty chill in brighton oh
yeah i mean people come up and ask for
pictures and stuff but if you say no
they're like yeah okay
yeah because it was it was really weird
for me because
uh obviously now that uh i came back
from
you know living in japan for two years
and we started this podcast and before
that i like didn't show my face on
camera and like for the first time i
started to get recognized in this home
city that i like grew up in yeah so like
like like i would have thought that you
would have gotten recognized a lot or it
would have been like a daily occurrence
so
yeah i think initially when i moved it
probably was but then now people know
you're there they kind of right like
there's no sense of emergency right
right right right right some people
still have to like you look familiar but
then they don't really go any further
than that
yeah i guess like different sensibility
as well yeah we're saying yeah versus
america yeah yeah yeah yeah you'll hear
aaron as starstruck yeah i don't think
so you guys brighton's a cool city come
visit brighton it's an amazing city no
don't you'll ruin it
it's nice i like it
don't make it to vidcon
yeah
we thought about that for a while as
well like maybe we'll move to la still
and
brighton's just nice every time we go
back it's like man we have a nice house
we live in a nice part of town yeah
people are cool the restaurants are
really nice yeah like la just seems
intense you know from my experience with
it it's it's two city i feel and
especially like it's definitely the
culture behind it is definitely you know
i feel run by this like you know stardom
culture it's a big marauder yeah exactly
exactly it doesn't really because i i
said it before that when i went on tour
you get a good sense of like life in
different pockets of the world yeah yeah
yeah and then like going around
different states i was like oh this is
kind of like that state but you guys do
this instead and you kind of get a feel
for the culture a bit everything still
felt like quintessentially america yeah
yeah but then la is just a different
beast like
it it feels like we would go down the
streets and like walk around and you can
get a sense for the place like who's
walking around and who lives there and
like they're they're just a slice of
life yeah but la is so hard to find that
with yeah anywhere you walk in it which
is very few places it feels like
everyone's just there to work yeah no
one lives there yeah like every time i
meet like someone in la you just get
used to people introducing themselves
than saying what they do immediately you
know normally that's like
a few layers down in the conversation
but in la it feels like okay i'm this
person by the way i also do this i'm
working on this this this and that's
just like i that was just like very
forward for me sorry yeah
yeah working on screenplays
propositioned one in an uber well in l.a
and then
on the same trip we heard a guy walking
down the street he's like i just don't
think they're going to go for that
screenplay maybe if we pitched on this
other one i was like no [ __ ] way
people talk like this
it was i was like in a movie
walk on set
yeah you're in like the traffic and
there's someone like practicing their
lines and like the car next to you or
something
yeah because you hear horror stories of
people who move there and then like
change and become hollywood yeah yeah
yeah i think it's impossible not to i
that was another thing i was kind of
afraid to move there in case i didn't
come this monster yeah yeah he just
because i'm a sponge i'll just take in
what's around me and i'm yeah like if
i'm surrounded by that all the time
that's all you know and yeah yeah it's
very disconnected from the rest of the
world i feel like when we come back here
and we live here it's like
people don't talk the same they're not
talking about stocks all the time
like investing in houses
[Laughter]
i think that's like another big reason
why like i probably could never see
myself living in a place like that
because it's like yeah again like i
don't want to be that guy yeah you know
who who turns into that right yeah yeah
and yeah like you know i love all the
people i love all my friends who live in
l.a for sure they're all amazing people
but you know at the same time yeah it is
kind of like
another world yeah it doesn't feel real
i mean i have so many friends there and
so many of them just complain about l.a
all the time like they don't even want
to be there yeah they can't leave
it's the best place for this type of
work yeah yeah it is i'm never more
productive than when i go to la yeah
it's true sure there's always something
that you could be working on yeah yeah
yeah infinite connections right yeah i
feel like if you want to network then
you know la is the place to be yeah uh
but at what cost
no part of you that ever wanted to try
living in korea for a bit
i don't think so i think it's too much
of a culture shift yeah that makes sense
um
and i i'm a very social person and i
feel like i would not integrate as much
as i would want to
right i feel like i would be very scared
and nervous to like
speak korean to people and
i would never go out and join like a
book club or go meet people at like an
event or anything right right right
right
would you scary would you ever
are you planning to i guess like stay in
like uk and ireland then do you see
yourself like
sticking around this kind of area i
think it's i think it's nice enough i
think if we've carved out like a knife a
nice
niche yeah like place for us here and
yeah i think again it keeps me very like
grounded and keeps me like very in touch
with the world yeah and like walking
around here and in brighton i feel like
i'm actually like a part of like the
bigger picture yeah
yeah i know that's awesome it doesn't
feel like a bubble like everywhere else
but i i've done la for like three months
at one point and it was really fun i had
a lot of friends there and like every
night was something to hang out with
yeah so many good restaurants in l.a
yeah yeah that is one thing that every
time i go back to la i'm looking forward
to the restaurant and foods it's like
the only place outside of korea that has
good korean barbecue yeah yeah yeah yeah
is really good yeah i'm so i'm so
excited for that like because we're
going to la actually in about
like two weeks two three weeks i'm
recording yeah yeah from the time of
this recording and the first place i
always want to hit up is the korean
barbecue of course yeah you can eat meat
it's just insane yeah you get it in
japan it's like yeah it's all you can
eat maybe maybe if you're lucky and
we're nice but probably well korean bbq
i feel is very different to like
yakiniku yeah yeah yeah yeah it is
yeah yeah it is both amazing but it's
like it's it's definitely a different
vibe yeah yeah yeah do you have any
favorite korean dishes or just any
favorite like food in general
um i mean i'm a sucker for just a good
piping pop
oh god yeah like a proper korean one
like the stone bowl yeah yeah still
crackling as it comes yeah
it's just really good and it's nice and
spicy and warm and like it's good winter
food but there's there's also another
one called i think it's so long tang
which is like
it's like a ox bone broth
yeah i've had that once it's very tasty
it's it's tasty and it just like it's it
cleans the soul that's what it feels
like i remember i remember one time like
i was like like one of the most hungover
i've ever been in korea i felt awful and
had like the
the oxblown soup and it just felt like
my body was just like so refreshed
afterwards i don't know i don't know
what you guys put in there but like
it's like the ancient herbal like
like the ancient herbal medicine that
they like that everyone talks about
that's what it felt like
yeah yeah you're right just mix it in
yeah i'm a big fan of like a mandu chige
which is like a dumpling stew as well
okay okay any of those like it's like
stuff that i wouldn't get here really
and i was like yeah
it's so good and there's probably a lot
of stuff that you can't really get here
right yeah at least not proper yeah and
i'm afraid i still stand by the korean
food's my favorite food in the world i
love korean food i love it yeah korean
fried chicken is also [ __ ] incredible
i don't realize that koreans have
perfected fried chicken best yeah i have
the best i i think koreans have the best
fried chicken in the world to be fair i
don't think i've ever heard or met
anyone who has said that they don't like
korean food so yeah it's pretty
difficult haven't had it that's a lot of
this yeah well i haven't had the good
one yeah yeah but yeah because i guess
like korean food wasn't as popular i
guess like uh like 10 years ago or
something because i remember like i
never even tried korean food until
around like 10 about like 10 years ago
and then because it was all like you
know you see like indian food or like
japanese food or chinese food and like i
never got a chance to try korean cuisine
and then remember the first time trying
it i was like why is this not more more
popular yeah why is this not more
widespread
yeah k-pop are doing a lot of the heavy
lifting on that
yes yes yes spreading into the world
which is great because now we have like
a good uh korean restaurant in brighton
called kogi which is just me yeah
um but it does like legit korean food
yeah cool so good i gotta check it out i
think that's new is it is it new since
uh or is it been around for a while um i
think it was right before pandemic and
i'm so happy that pandemic didn't kill
it okay because i was very worried i was
like you haven't been open long enough
to like have a float of cash yeah yeah
survive this but i think they're still
going strong yeah because i feel like in
brighton now there's just like like
there's been a lot of restaurants been
popping up now because when i because i
i obviously moved out brighton like
about like just before pandemic and even
then i wasn't really living in brighton
as well as more living in thailand so
just seeing like one thing that i've
learned from japan is i love food
culture i love restaurant culture and i
come back to brighton and now there's
like every cuisine under the sun there's
like cool restaurants i'm like [ __ ] yes